CLAUDIO: --the Google Drive
SDK question time--
I'm Claudio.
ALI: And I'm Ali.
CLAUDIO: This is Ali.
We're two engineers in the
Google Drive SDK Developer
Relations Team.
Today, we're going to answer
some of your questions from
SecOverflow and some of the
questions we got from you
about the Google Drive
application development.
I think we're going to
start with this one.
It's about search criteria.
The question says, how to set
criteria on SupFills in the
query parameter.
So this user has a complex
tree structure.
And he wants to retrieve files
and folders and so on.
But I think, before answering
that, we should explain what
the search criteria are
in Google Drive
and how to use that.
ALI: Thanks, Claudio.
So when you list files with the
Google Drive API, you have
the opportunity to give
a query parameter.
Now that query parameter--
q, it's called-- specifies
a search on the files and
returns only the
ones you want.
So there are a number of fields
you can search on, the
title, the full text of the
body, the parents of the file,
i.e., the folders where the
file lives in, whether the
file has been trashed.
And all of these are listed
in our documentation.
Now, the question is
specifically, here, asking.
CLAUDIO: About looking for files
in specific folders and
also how to find those files
that are in the root folder.
ALI: OK.
So the way that the questioner
wants to do this is by doing
query parameters
on sub-fields.
So instead of just checking
whether there is a parent, to
look whether the parent
is the root.
Unfortunately, that's
not possible.
The query language is not
generated, dynamically, based
on what's available.
We have specified the
fields that we want.
And that's so that the queries
can run quickly and
efficiently.
So unless the query parameter is
provided, you won't be able
to use that.
And you can't invent your own
arbitrarily-nested queries.
That won't work,
unfortunately.
CLAUDIO: But you can use some
Boolean logic to extend the
queries, like End.
ALI: Yes, of course.
So you can join, or conjoin,
multiple query bits together.
So you can say, the title
contains Claudio is great.
And the file has not
been trashed.
CLAUDIO: OK.
Which is always true.
ALI: Which is always true.
So you can join them with
the And parameter.
And once you send that query,
obviously, the query parameter
itself becomes URL encoded
when you send it.
So it becomes this long thing.
But then, the results
are joined.
So only those files which meet
all the criteria are provided.
CLAUDIO: If you know Boolean
logic, what you expect is to
have And, Or, and Not.
So we have all of them.
ALI: So currently,
we only have And.
CLAUDIO: Not even Or?
ALI: Not even Or.
So we don't have Or,
at the moment.
We only have And.
Unfortunately, the way to do Or,
at the moment, would be to
do two separate queries and
then join them together.
And that would be the Or.
So unfortunately, no.
But that's definitely something
that, as the query
language becomes more mature,
we would look to add.
The other part of it is
negations, as in Not.
I think that's probably
more useful than Or.
CLAUDIO: I mean, Or, developers
can easily come up
with a solution that
doesn't require Or.
As you said, two queries can
return the same result set of
an Or query.
Not is probably a bigger
limitation.
But are we addressing it?
ALI: So again, that's something
that we're looking
to add soon.
My personal opinion is, I think
it would greatly enhance
the query language, even
far more than Or.
But having said that--
CLAUDIO: Going back to the
question, there's another part
that is important.
So this developer is trying to
specifically query for files
inside folders and folders
inside folders.
So we have a way to look for the
elements inside a folder.
And each folder is identified
by a unique ID, like every
other file and every other
resource in the API.
But there's a special case,
which is the Root Folder.
And in fact, developers can
always access the Root Folder
by using the special alias Root,
instead of the long ID,
which you retrieve from
the API itself.
So in any case, you need
to use the root.
You can just type Root
instead of a long ID.
ALI: So there are three
things actually here.
Now, what this person wants--
I think we can solve it
in a different way.
What do you think about
that, Claudio?
So firstly, there are two ways
of looking inside a folder.
Either you can search for the
files for which the parent is
that folder.
Or you can actually list the
children of that folder.
Now, if you do it the first
way, using the query
parameter, I search for
files that have the
parent of that folder.
Do you know the query
parameter?
Parent end, something
or another--
CLAUDIO: Yeah, end is one of
the keywords you can use in
the query library.
ALI: So using that, that has the
advantage because you can
join that with a MIME Type
Query for specifically
returning folders.
If you've watched this session
in the past, you know that
folders in the Google Drive API
are defined by having a
special MIME type.
So they're just files.
But they have this special
MIME type.
And obviously they don't
have any binary data
associated with them.
But what you can do then,
is you can say, OK.
I want to search for files that
are in a certain folder
but also have the folder
MIME types.
And now you're only searching
for folders
within a certain folder.
So if you want to search for
folders within the root, the
first component would
be the root part.
And the second component would
be the folder type.
And again, here's where Not
would be really useful.
Because then, if you just wanted
files, you could search
for things that were not
the folder MIME type.
But unfortunately that's not
possible at the moment.
CLAUDIO: So you said that a
folder has a list of children.
And a document has a
list of parents.
So basically, from one you
can get to the other.
And from the file, you can also
get back to the folder.
Is there any difference in
what you can achieve with
these two feeds?
ALI: So not really.
They're pretty symmetric.
CLAUDIO: So it's probably just
a convenience for developers,
so that they can start from the
research they have and go
back to the folder, or start
from the folder and get back
to the intended document.
ALI: And the third way, as well,
they can actually query
against these.
So you can start from
the folder.
You can start from the file.
Or you can start completely
outside both, if you happen to
know an ID or even if you want
to start from the root, as
Claudio said, using
the Root alias.
CLAUDIO: OK.
Let's move to another question.
ALI: Yeah.
So just before we go, this is
a really common problem.
People are traversing Google
Drive to try and get the
folder hierarchy.
It's a common problem.
So perhaps, we should write some
sample code or something.
CLAUDIO: Maybe we should.
And we should also highlight
that folders are actually,
let's say, collections.
So a document may belong in
multiple collections.
ALI: Exactly.
CLAUDIO: Yeah.
That's why you have a
parent list and not
just a single parent.
Remember, it's not exactly
a folder structure.
I mean, they're represented
as folders in the UI.
But the same file can be
categorized in multiple folders.
ALI: And obviously, that would
depend how your app wants to
handle that.
If you're mapping to a regular
file structure, you're going
to have to think of a way
of handling that.
And I don't think there's
any particularly good
solution for that.
CLAUDIO: Yeah.
You probably have to have a
single regional file and then
links to it in the file system
and things like that.
Well, the follow-up question was
about the Not operator for
query parameters, for queries.
And as you said, there is
no negation operator.
ALI: Yeah, unfortunately not.
We would love that.
If you feel like contributing
on how you would prefer that
to look and things like that,
then obviously, we'd like to
hear back from you.
CLAUDIO: How do they give us
feedback, if they want?
ALI: You can send us an email.
Or you could even make a
question about that.
CLAUDIO: OK.
Let's move on to another
question.
ALI: Right.
CLAUDIO: We're still talking
about how Files feed.
And this user, the question is
called Google Drive using .Net
API exportLinks empty.
So it's not exactly about .Net,
it's very interesting.
It's about the export links.
What are the export links?
ALI: So Google Docs types,
as in Google Docs, Google
Spreadsheets, Google Drawings,
Google Presentations, they can
all be exported to various
formats, using the API.
Now, the type of export that
you can perform, i.e., the
file that it becomes, really
depends on the type.
So you can imagine a Google Docs
might want to be exported
to, obviously, PDF, OpenOffice,
Microsoft Word,
these kind of things.
And a spreadsheet, likewise,
would be exportable to
different types.
So you don't know, unless you
know the type of file, what it
can be exported to.
Luckily, in the About feed,
which is kind of like a feed
that displays loads of data for
the specific user, there
is a list of the export
formats for each type.
So in that list you look
up your type of file.
And then it will show
the export format.
When later you're writing your
application, you can predict
what kind of exports
it will be.
CLAUDIO: In a similar way, the
same About feed includes a
list of import formats.
ALI: Exactly.
CLAUDIO: So they list the pairs
of Source Formats and
Destination Formats we
can import from.
ALI: Exactly.
So without actually grabbing any
files, for that user, you
can see what imports and what
exports they can do.
CLAUDIO: But that's a general
thing, you know.
So you know that, let's say,
for any Google Doc,
you can get a PDF.
But then for each document, you
can also get, or export,
the same document in
different formats.
And that's what the
exports links are.
So when you retrieve the
metadata for a document, for a
file store on Google Drive--
together with the rest of the
fields you get, you also
obtain a list of the
export links.
ALI: That's right.
CLAUDIO: So let's say
it's a document.
You get an export link for PDF
format and a link to it, the
export link for TXT file, if
available and a list to it.
ALI: Now, these export links
are actually just
conveniences, so that you can
just grab the link and use it.
If you look at them, you can
see that they're fairly
predictable.
And just by adding a query
parameter, you can
choose which one.
Now, these export links do map
exactly to the allowable
export formats for those
types of file.
So to recap, remember, this is
just Google Docs types that we
perform these exports on.
Imports, obviously, anything
that can be imported into
these Google Docs format.
So here we're really
highlighting some of the
differences between native
Google Docs files, like Google
Docs, spreadsheets,
presentations, et cetera.
And what we call binary files,
a JPEG or a PDF or
these kind of things.
So you have a bit more control
on how you can export them.
This is a really useful feature
because, recently,
we've added the ability to open
these Google Docs files
directly from the Drive UI.
In the same way that you can
write an app to edit images,
you can also write an app, not
quite to edit a Google Doc,
but to edit the exported
representation of a Google Doc.
So if you've got an application
that faxes PDFs,
for example, you can
register that.
And then the user can open a
Google Doc file as a PDF on
your application.
And then that will be faxed
or whatever you
want to do with that.
So we think that's a really
useful feature.
And while highlighting the
difference, it also shows how
you can use different types of
files in the same kind of way.
CLAUDIO: I just wanted to add
that, as you said, the Export
URLs are pretty easy to guess.
But don't do it.
We can always change
the URL format.
And you should never trust
guessing URLs.
And any time you want to export
a file from Google
Drive, you should get the file
metadata, check the export
links, find the one you want
for the specific format you
want, and get the
link from there.
We can always add new formats.
So you have to check the list of
available formats any time
you want to use those.
ALI: Yeah.
And to continue with that, if
your export format is missing,
then, well, that's again
something to let us know.
If it's going to be useful for
you, it's going to be likely
useful other people as well.
CLAUDIO: Yeah, perfect.
Then I would say that we can
move on to another question.
ALI: Yeah.
CLAUDIO: Now, the question is
about resumable upload.
It's Error 411, using resumable
upload in WebLogic.
WebLogic, I think, is
the least important
part of this question.
WebLogic is a Java framework.
But the protocol
to do resumable
upload is standard protocol.
So whatever the framework,
whatever the language, they
all have to implement
the same protocol.
This user is reporting
getting a 411
Exception, length required.
We already talked a bit about
resumable upload and all the
upload mechanisms in
other sessions.
But it's a complex protocol,
even if the libraries hide all
the details.
And in case you need to
implement it yourself, you
have to take care of
all the errors.
And what is this about?
ALI: So I can just about see
the stack trace from here.
I can tell that it's
Java because it's
about 60 lines long.
CLAUDIO: It is.
ALI: And I can see that
it's using GData
library for doing that.
So unfortunately, this
is probably a bug
in the library somewhere.
Because if the library is having
problems, then that
should be fixed.
But to see what the library is
doing wrong, I'm imagining
when it's sending--
well, this could be
one of two cases.
The first one is when
it initializes
the resumable upload.
When it initializes it,
you have to actually--
if you do send some metadata
along with that first request,
you have to specify
how long that is.
If you don't specify how
long that is, then
you'll get the 411.
Because you're trying
to do a post without
sending content length.
And that won't work.
The other time it could be
doing this is in the
continuation requests.
Each chunk you send, or if
you're sending the whole chunk
at the same time and depending
on how you're doing your
resumable upload, you have to
also specify the content
length then.
I think it's less likely to be
that because the continuation
request should be puts.
And this is a post.
Is that right?
CLAUDIO: Yeah, this is a post.
ALI: So it's pretty much
unlikely to be that.
And actually, I've seen the
code that does resumable
upload in this library.
And I don't think it covers the
case where you can send
metadata and the actual
initializer at the same time.
CLAUDIO: I would say that
there's a solution to this.
ALI: There's a fantastic
solution for this.
We should probably say
at the same time.
1, 2, 3
BOTH: Use the Drive API
ALI: Yeah, use the Drive API.
Because this is using the
old Documents List API.
And we're probably going to say
this on every single time
we do question time.
But really, using the Drive API,
the resumable upload part
of that library is considerably
better, I'd say.
Are we allowed to say that?
Yeah.
So it's considerably better.
One thing it does is it covers
this case of where you try and
send metadata at
the same time.
So we use that a lot more.
And if you're just uploading a
file, then you could use about
a third of the code.
CLAUDIO: Yeah.
So we have these
new libraries.
And we have a Java library
that can be--
I guess, it can be
used in WebLogic.
And this new library takes care
of everything you need to
do, when doing resumable
upload.
So you just have a method, an
easy method to call-- it's
probably like upload.
And that's it.
You didn't even have
to know that you're
doing resumable upload.
ALI: That's right.
And we have a full
sample in Java.
So the best recommendation for
this developer would be--
unless you're trying to
integrate this into a lot of
different applications, then
that's the way to do.
If you've already got the GData
application, and it's
heavy, then I guess,
unfortunately, we're going to
have to look to fix that
bug for that person.
Or the library is Open
Source of course.
So that can be fixed.
CLAUDIO: Yeah, all
the libraries.
The old ones, the GData one,
like this, and the new ones
are all Open Source.
And the samples are
also Open Source.
And feel free to report bugs.
But also, if you want to
contribute to the development
of these libraries,
and you find bugs.
Or you have better approaches
of patches to any of those.
We'd be really glad to get
your contribution.
ALI: Yeah, exactly.
And you know, some people just
want don't want to wait until
the next day, for
it to get fixed.
They just want to fix it.
CLAUDIO: You will fix everything
in one day?
Are you committing to it?
ALI: No.
CLAUDIO: Sorry, what
are did you say?
ALI: So yes, really,
we appreciate that.
CLAUDIO: OK.
Do we want to--
ALI: Yeah, we've got
time for one more.
Why not?
CLAUDIO: OK.
ALI: If we go up, because
I think we answered some
of them last time.
CLAUDIO: OK, yeah.
Going back.
ALI: Where's Chrome Web Store?
CLAUDIO: What about Chrome
Web Store registration?
ALI: So what about Chrome
Well, if you've written
a Drive app--
well, do you want to go?
CLAUDIO: So let's
start from this.
When we launched Drive API v1,
in April this year, the
applications that wanted to use
the Drive API had to be
registered on the Chrome
Web Store.
And users had to install
the application from
the Chrome Web Store.
This was a requirement that
we added by design.
But then, we got
some feedback.
We put a lot more
thought on it.
And when we launched the Drive
API v2, at Google I/O, at the
end of June, we decided to
drop this requirement.
So applications that want to
use the Drive API now don't
need to be on the Chrome
Web Store.
But they may still want to.
ALI: Right.
You may still want to.
And why is that?
Well, the Chrome Web Store,
currently, although not
required, is a really useful
marketing tool for your
application, for two reasons.
One, we have a collection
of Drive apps.
So if a user is thinking, hmm, I
want a Drive app, perhaps to
modify some images, and
yours fulfills that.
They can just see that in
the list, and that's
very easy to install.
So that's the first part.
The second part, and probably
way more powerful and a bit
more important is that when you
register with the Chrome
Web Store, you register
your manifest.
And with that manifest, you
register which kinds of file
you can open.
That's used by Google Drive,
the web-user interface, to
help users find your
application.
So if a user has a file that
can't be opened by the Google
Drive itself or by any
applications they have
installed, they will be
hinted to install
applications that can.
And that could include
your application.
This is, we think,
really important.
It allows you to virally
grow your application.
For example, if a user shares
a file with someone else, a
file that can only be opened
by your application, the
person they've shared it with
will then have a chance,
immediately, with a single
click, to go to your
application and install it.
And we think that's really,
really useful.
And we think that you should
be involved in
that, if you can.
And that's the advantage
that using the Chrome
Web Store gives you.
So it's pretty much a way
for users to find your
application, both inside the
Drive user interface and
inside Chrome Web Store.
Anything to add to
that, Claudio?
CLAUDIO: I think that
was perfect.
ALI: OK.
So apart from that, you don't
need to currently, but I
definitely would, if you've got
a user-facing application.
CLAUDIO: Well, it's
a marketing tool.
You want your application
to be discovered.
So you want to be there.
There's a collection for Drive
applications, and you want
your application to be there.
Of course, there are some
requirements for your
application to be there.
So we want good applications
to be there.
So remember, you have to post
some screenshots of your
application, a good
description of it.
And remember, you also get
reviews from people.
So of course, when other users
go there to look for an
application, the first thing
they will look at is the other
users' reviews.
So make sure your app works
great and description is good.
And whenever you get some
feedback from the users,
remember to address
those feedbacks.
ALI: Yeah, good.
Great advice.
CLAUDIO: Thank you.
And I think that we're done.
ALI: I think, yeah, we
should wrap that up.
CLAUDIO: We're done for today.
And we're going to see
you again next week.
ALI: Yup, thank you.
CLAUDIO: Thank you, everyone.
ALI: Thank you all for
your questions.